[Music]
it's the patreon show so you know what
that means
it's wednesday i know what that means
retards
um i was gonna you know what i knew you
were i knew you were doing something
because i looked at the clock and i'm
like
can i can i point this out [ __ ]
i want to find out okay i want to point
out this is good it's good it's good
he has his own merchandise
of course thick boy merchandise uh with
with three c's
um
he's wearing
i don't know those like the sunglasses
like elizabeth taylor would wear
i don't know what's up with the
sunglasses that he's rocking here he
looks like he's going to be calling
everyone darling yes exactly
so we've been [ __ ] so great at
checking out the thick boy content
um
i think that mark harvey guy wasn't was
it was was on a burner account on the
clip channel because i put the mark
harvey stuff we did yesterday up
and it was like you guys are just haters
and like yeah i know we said we were
haters
yeah that's what we do i know 888 yeah
we flew him all the way from nashville
tennessee he is the number four by the
way coach they
printer flume coach
lightweight in the world this dude has
more fight options than a youtuber right
now did you hear his line
because the youtubers are all fighting
huh this [ __ ] boom mic coming into
[ __ ]
look at the boomerang
um
[Laughter]
that is
he's just everything about him
right here dude you've achieved peak
virginia
oh [ __ ] that's hilarious dude everything
about him sucks
we flew him all the way from nashville
tennessee he is the number four
lightweight in the world this dude has
more fight options than a youtuber right
now
the way it is
can i say something yeah
he's stealing ap spit
that's ap's [ __ ]
slowly like pokes in hold on it looks
just like an ap bit
okay here it is here we go options than
a youtuber right now
see at normal speed it's funniest i i
need i need one of those little whistle
kazoo things you know what i mean
dude i want to say i'm sorry ap i did
not know brandon shaw was going to start
stealing your your [ __ ] oh everybody
steals ap's jokes it's funny that was
one of my favorite early little things
that ap like the little details that he
added to his show yeah was just every
once in a while that boom mic would just
dangle in the shots
to literally animate fuck-ups into your
show as well
i'm a youtuber right now he is the it's
oh my
god okay come on now you got to
photoshop dicks now you got a photoshop
dicks ufc cap
no
this has to be a bit is it a bit you
think it's
so bad
it's if it's not a bit dude then this is
like beyond egregious wouldn't you just
hold on hold on maybe maybe so if it is
a bit let's say it's a bit right
if it is a bit right this is the what's
the bit what's a bit what's the bit that
he's an idiot
is that the bit yeah
it may be hey man maybe he's leaning
into it
is the ufc cash cow come on he's the ufc
come on man no that's oh
that's real no sorry sorry that come on
man that wasn't frustrated that
commandment he's not that good of an
actor the ufc cash cal come on
that's he's oh
this is my favorite thing brendan's ever
done does this boom operator not not
respect him either i think his boom like
operator is probably like on his way out
and just thought maybe i'll give him a
boop yeah he's gonna go work for tiger
belly i don't think anyone that works
for him respects him at all oh my god do
you know what i i would have thought it
was a bit until the come on come on yeah
i really thought maybe he's doing it
because he started getting agreed just
to wait that come on man like was
because if if he if it were a bit
he would have been like come on man like
he would have hammed it up because he
has no good like
instincts to make something feel real
that felt real
by the way
more time can i point something out i
would 100 do this to marsh if we were
filming something like this if you don't
think i would you have no idea we have
done that to each other i know yeah
we've put dixons and you know what the
other one will just
just laugh
what are you doing here stop than a
youtuber right now he is the ufc cash
cal come on come on man come on come on
come on man
i wonder if it was like i i'm wondering
if they're laughing behind the camera
like if they're trying to
we are
12 seconds into this video this is the
best brendan shop video i think i've
ever seen
he can't stop laughing not kidding
it's unbelievable that's
come on man
come on man
oh [ __ ]
okay we look guys we can
i'm bummed because we're not going to
top that but anyway
he's a ufc cash cow he has one big old
fight coming up it's michael
he did it again they did it again what
the boom mic operator did it again
oh god
oh chandler god damn it dude michael bro
if you're gonna do it you gotta do it
right dude i'm a professional oh it is
your [ __ ] together is it it's michael
chandler
oh
oh on this week's food truck diaries and
i'm feeding them kelly's sweet barbecue
yes we're both care if it was a bit that
was the funniest thing that brendan
schwab's ever done hey look man
i'm gonna say two things that's the
funniest thing he's ever done and i very
highly believe it was probably somebody
else's idea it doesn't matter
it was somebody else's idea that was
funny carnivore let's go
just got to be close to my mouth i know
i know the direction of this of the
sound
you don't
[Music]
i'm gonna skip the intro if you guys
don't mind
thank you yeah because i don't think
anybody really cares um
no signs
that guy's ear hurts my eyes jesus
christ oh my god these guys man i don't
know how oh i don't i mean that's i mean
all the grapplers are like that by the
way that's [ __ ] rough man permanently
disfigured yeah the exact same thing i'm
a fighter dude i would just have my ears
cut off
so you want to be like a a pit bull
have your ears clipped i mean
you just you'll still be able to hear
barbecue sauce on the side
ribs and brisket anything to drink
god i can't look at that how does he you
can he use airpods
like
it probably limits his headphone
selections right he could only do like
the cans that go over the ears mm-hmm
reasons so we have to be really careful
the other day we got it shredded he is
shredded he is shredded but but it's
more mental than um
this rain i mean he's shredded bro i've
seen i know the rain's a sponsor but
the other day i was like ill rain energy
drink and some people like oh i [ __ ]
love it have you ever tried rain is it
anybody so flat yes i have it's meh it's
not exciting the car did the carbonation
this is a funny one
it tastes better the canadian rain
actually tastes better than the us one
it's weird it's like made in different
facility
you guys have different laws on sugar
and [ __ ] yeah
yeah our um our reins have barely any
carbonation in it and then when it's
been open for about 10 minutes it's
pretty much flat so that's the only
reason i don't like it i don't taste bad
it's just i like a little carbonation in
my [ __ ]
just like
so guys i don't think it's fair i don't
think it's fair that brandon's shop gets
his own merch right i think you guys you
know you guys need you guys have merch
but i think you guys need more royce i
sent you a design feel free it's all
yours
uh it's very subtle
but uh you can use it for your store if
you'd like
for like for you guys for rotc merch you
can use that design what what is that
i don't know what
why don't you tell me
what is it royce
also guys uh lena and me made you
something it's in the show
oh no
it's in the shower
uh
people would totally buy a pickle
gashard
look at the girl
all right that's really funny
[Laughter]
that's [ __ ]
hilarious oh [ __ ]
jesus christ hey look man at least the
first time brendan's ever made us laugh
you got to give him that you got to give
him that one
broken clocks and whatnot yeah um
uh
on the brendan thing did you guys notice
that he has like a [ __ ] a picture of
joe over his shoulder oh yeah i know
check this out yeah yeah yeah look yeah
for those that don't know here i'll
screen it yeah he has a picture of his
of his internet daddy behind him
yeah look at that
he should have been you know what he
should get is like
joe rogan prayer candles dude that would
be like if i had a picture of [ __ ]
like merge a royce on my wall
you don't you don't
no i have a picture of you
oh okay that's fair okay
um
so that when the jdif looks through my
[ __ ] my webcam they see my jewish
friend you know that i'm cool
that's fair
anyway enough of the shop
yeah we got it he's an idiot it's
something funny though good for him hey
man look we gave him credit that was
very funny
with the 2020x game look in the show
links don't forget on screen
okay
i won't bring it on screen
oh no
come on man don't make i can't you know
i can't pull that up
oh no
virgin muted himself because he knows
oh my god could i put that up on the
screen i don't see why i couldn't i made
it i tried to make it i made it enough
so that there's no actual penis
yeah there's no penis there
there's still pure discretion there's no
penis there
no [ __ ] it
that's
amazing
thick
boy had to angle it this is a thick boy
indeed
[Music]
it's so childish
i'm gonna post that i'm gonna post it on
twitter it's so good
it's so i can't i can't not look at it
so great
uh what you guys get on the patreon show
hey you know what you should be happy
um no this will probably get clipped
i'm not stupid it might be a patron show
but i have a feeling this one little
segment might end up getting clipped
well why there's nothing wrong with it
because the thumbnail alone would
probably make us a couple of bucks i
know
oh no jim eagle i pulled that up on my
work computer gonna get a call from it
in a minute
why would a rational times call you at
work